[Music]
it's not what you think news it's not
what you think
submitted by mr. Rogers Rogers sir a
girl is horrified after her dad thinks
he found her sex toy oh my god I would
die did you have a sex toy with you in
high school no I wish I did in high
foreign [__] well you got to think
when I was when I was in high school
Internet was barely coming out
technically you had a sex toy it was the
showerhead oh I had a sex toy it was
this Wiggly pen that vibrates like it
was a pen and you turn it on and goes
hard you need a vibrating pen so you
could you could draw squiggly things
like it's a funny pen like it just
Wiggles like how did you did you put
your butt no no no no I you know where
the [__] what is this part this part
of the dick chod oh that part yeah this
portable why do you ask me I don't know
what it define what the part is your
sexual I thought you would understand
what is that the between the balls so
like if this was my wiener and then I
pull back the foreskin it's the most oh
you talked to you about the Asians hair
split area yes the Asians
yeah I would just [__] if the part of
the bigger it looks like it looks like
very some mushroom cap exactly that's
the it's the bottom of the Spade yeah
exactly
my Wiggly pen I would I would be giving
my [__] head fade every day I never
borrowed anything from you I don't know
where the [__] anything's been dude good
knows as Loki though I believe that that
pen was made by a pervert
knowing that kids are gonna use that as
a sex toy because if I was a girl that
would be the perfect weapon of choice I
never thought of putting anything I
didn't even realize I had a vagina know
the older like I never cuz you realize
like around 1718 very well
yeah by then for sure but I think I
don't know I think of maybe like 14
doesn't that's pretty normal
that's high school cuz I don't know when
you said that I was thinking like
elementary school yeah that's kind of
when it started like fourth grade fifth
grade I remember one time I was at my
friend's house and then we were playing
and wrestling right and then I took a
break to [__] rub my dick against his
bed because his bed was super soft and
it was like no I literally like like
longer like wrestling dad and in my dick
like started rubbing up against the bed
and I was like oh this is kind of a nice
you said that oh you said that oh yeah
What did he say he was like oh let me
try good I had Rams know I had friends
were like we would just sit and watch TV
and you know how you had the short
shorts like this like the super super
short shorts that are like this right he
would put his hand in his [__] pants
like that and start playing with his
balls yeah you had some weird friends
dude did that [__] I had I had a friend
that was addicted to jacking off and
then he didn't this was like in third or
fourth grade and I thought he was funny
because he was always playing with his
wiener like I wasn't I wasn't doing it
but I think he was like he got me into
it like this the new trend but he would
do it like while we were you know how
I'm in elementary you shoosh you share
the desk right there's like two people
here two people there whatever so I
would sit here he's over here there's a
girl right here and he's just [__]
ripping his dick out and going what the
[__] this is how he jacked off this is
the head right and then he would put
four fingers and you Wow
[Applause]
such a vivid memory even I remember cuz
cuz I didn't know that was wrong I just
thought it was so funny that he would be
doing that oh my god for that in
elementary school is I'd be playing in
the jungle gym and I'd be climbing up
the pole and then I never like I
remember I never really thought about it
that time I was just remember thinking
like oh this actually feels good my like
you're riding the pole yeah I think I
was like in second grade no I was like
little kids are [__] weird yeah you
know why I said okay so this is why I
said weird cuz I pictured you said that
right but I didn't picture little
Tiffany I just pictured a bunch of
little snot-nosed kids playing on the
playground with like dirt and [__] all
over their face and their hairs all
[__] up cuz you know your mom used to
take you very presentable to school but
like come like recess you're all [__]
up so I pick Cherie bunch of [__] up
looking kids just rubbing and not see
not that I know this true though I used
to [__] the monkey bars before after you
licked your hands
I don't think about [__] like this now
that I do every time I see kiddo just
start screaming at them no cuz I used to
[__] the monkey bars and then I don't
know what I was doing but I just know
that if I like rub rubbed it enough I'll
end up having an orgasm
so something like like that's second or
third period of getting orgasm off the
monkey bars and then one time I
remembered this sixth grader was like yo
are you hoping that [__] and I don't
even know what hug be met but I just
thought there's like no the monkey bars
like this and it's like this [__] so
I'm not even really [__] it so I
grabbed the monkey bar and here's the
Paul right I climb it like this and for
some reason what I went like this enough
I would just have orgasm
oh [__] that's kind of similar sort of
what I would do I would just be like
climbing up the pole and I'm like that
feels good to get up like I did and I
hung upside down and that was it you
never played chicken fight and then like
if someone wraps their legs around you
you felt boy or girl like that was fun
like I like I hated that [__] they tried
to do that to me and I would fall in
like stop I want to climb yeah but you
don't follow you just stay there and
you'd like fight them but I couldn't
they would wrap around it would wrap
their legs are on you right but then
they would wrap it around and then it
touches your like Weiner area you're
like
I don't remember any of this [__] dude
naughty nice and you probably don't
remember about me sure you did it
probably I don't remember
eventually you're a boy like boys are a
little curious with their dick and I
liked it so much I started [__] the
tree at home boy no you guys are weird
any of this [__] okay why'd you write -
you - oh you did the bar thing no I
didn't do the bar thing it's just like I
was climbing up a soccer goalie because
I think something got caught there
something bad and when I was hiding up
on it I was like what the [__] is this
they're like this is sliding down like a
slug we gotta go to [__] like a park
and we just see all these kids I'm
[__] do it because of you guys that's
all I'm gonna see now all these kids
just [__] [__] now looks like we're
just sliding that but they're just
having a little bit more fun than they
should come these kids what the [__] you
smiling for [__] I'm suggesting a smile
I know
[Laughter]
so Emily she looks like this is Emily
here I don't even know what word power
does she
her dad found her sex toys oh yes I'm
not sure how old she is it's just this
story because she tweeted this out man
she looks like anything from like 16 all
the way to like 25 that was a team I
think she's a team they don't mention
how old she is though but anyway so she
ended up tweeting this out she said this
was so awkward
oh my god my dad really assumed the
worst and then accompanied with this
screenshot and says Emily a power
charger they yeah Emily where are you
when
you get home we need to talk she says
friends helps why and this is the photo
of the little charger why is she in
trouble for having that well he said
well I found this why are you making
these purchases what that is disgusting
you shouldn't waste your money if you
have these kinds of needs I suggest you
don't leave this [__] laying around you
should put it in all caps dad what do
you think that is he's like those things
people buy a censor those disgusting
toys that vibrate I'm not that old Emily
so it's disgusting toys that vibrate
what a funny has that dad that's my
portable charger I use that for
Disneyland to charge my phone oh my god
what were you doing in my stuff by the
way he's like don't tell your mom sorry
I need a chapstick by the way be safe
when you come with that that's pretty
awesome he wasn't that pitch yeah you
were just saying like dude that's dirty
like keep it hidden if you want to use
it just don't leave it laying around
like if you had these needs leave it
laying on I wonder what his reaction was
when he was like getting through you
know I really would it be like he's all
[Laughter]
how dare you that's [__] awful should
have got a better Brad I still can't go
into thank you guys were [__] jungle
gyms dude right we were [__] jungle
gyms just I can't get over because I'm
jealous I didn't think of that [__] you
guys remember the first time you ever
ejaculated yup why because I was ten
[__] the tree or eleven I was [__]
the tree and then after I was I didn't I
didn't even I was [__] the tree but
how does climb the tree [__] treat
and then I remember I I went back to go
watch TV except this time I was like
sticky down there and wet and I'm like
what the [__] and then I would pull that
I went back to watch cartoons lucky my
parents I'm like what the [__] is this
[__] and they don't I found out it was
sperm or ejaculatory by 10 or 11
Oh baby already yeah but then first your
dick dry heaves for like the longest
time you don't talk yeah it's like it's
like that you get the orgasm feeling but
no no come comes out when you first
jackoff it's like
hmm and then so you get that bra be like
hmm and then and then you you orgasm
you're like wow what's that oh I'm so
meek what happened that's so weird and
then and then you know how like after
you come you feel all like Oh what did I
just do like it's weird right
yeah and then you have like normal
senses for like 10 seconds
[Music]
[Applause]
you